[Music]
does anyone else love Taco Bell as much
as I do
bean burritos Kato soft taco beefy
Fritos ooh crunchy tacos beef supreme
chalupa I'm in Utah in a random town on
i-15 going south from Salt Lake City
I'm headed to one of the most special
places in the world to me which is
southern Utah I dressed burrito hot
frito taco frito it has Fritos in this
hike that we're going on called the
subway only 80 people are allowed to do
it every day so they have limited
permits and they give them out in a
lottery even if you could chosen then
you get to do the hike and we got lucky
and we won the lottery we've got a
permit and now I need a map
[Music]
okay I got mouths oh gosh at that time
to eat borders put the maps down in and
bring it on in
I'm trying to find
it's almost bedtime but there's a ghost
town about abandoned places that is just
so haunting and I just love it I'm
excited for tomorrow I've never been
inside of these really really narrow
canyons so pretty excited to go explore
but for now bedtime
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right this is a giant Canyon and
really what we're standing on right now
is a huge slab of rock and when I say
huge I mean like hundreds of kilometers
long look at us if you were to follow
this slab of rock a little bit more
southeast from here you would get to the
lowest point which is the Grand Canyon
this huge slab of rock gets called the
Colorado Plateau has lots of little
canyons has a big Canyon the Grand
Canyon but it has lots of other little
canyons one of them is Zion Canyon which
is the canyon we are hanging out in
right now actually technically were
right next door to Zion Canyon in kolob
canyon anyway these are all canyons that
tell the story of a slab of rock that
has been whittled down over millions of
years by erosion we are descending into
the valley that has been cut out by the
water and we're actually gonna go into a
little canyon a very narrow canyon that
is a very young canyon meaning it hasn't
been cut very wide and you will see why
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
chicka Bow Wow
[Music]
it's technically backcountry here
meaning there's no official trail no
markings
you just create your own adventure which
is
[Music]
okay this is slippery
it's good this one's super solid okay
I'm good I'm good
famous last words
[Music]
so these big walls of rock you can see
are full of layers tons of layers layers
layers layers layers layers all of these
layers in the rock tell a little story
of what was happening on the earth in
this area at some point millions of
years ago
youtell used to be in the ocean under
the water and then it wasn't and then it
was and then it wasn't and then it was
so every time the ocean would rise he
would bring a new set of minerals and
sediment into this area and it would
that would become the new bottom of the
ocean in this area and then the ocean
would go away for a little bit and that
sediment would settle and solidify and
eventually turn into rock so what you
get is this story that's etched into the
rock layer by layer by layer and it's
just beautiful
water starts to get you doing okay back
there
oh I'm not don't worry I'm not worrying
about you and eventually with enough
water and flooding going through these
cracks in what was once the solid rock
you get something that looks like this
the canyon we're going to is it much
younger canyon it's still in the process
of being widened what that looks like I
guess we'll find out very soon we're
about to get into this Canyon
[Music]
that's where it all begins right here
this really narrow cut out in the rock
is cut up by this water and now every
second that this water runs through here
it cuts it a little bit more in a
million years Union
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
here's the big caveat though not all
rocks erode equally they erode in
different ways and on different
timescales and that I think is really
important as soon as we get into this
Canyon we'll see why
[Music]
oh my gosh Wow Wow Wow Wow
so like I was saying not all rock layers
erode equally the majority of Zion the
thickest part of the sediment is what's
called Navajo Sandstone which is really
really hard to erode right underneath
the Navajo Sandstone is this Kayenta
stone more of a mud stone or silt stone
it was deposited before the Navajo
Sandstone and it was a much more silty
muddy thing and it erodes a lot easier
and so these formations you can see this
happening frozen in time where the
Navajo Sandstone is resistant to being
eroded but the Chi enta right underneath
it is getting more and more eroded
because it just reacts so much more to
water
and that's why you get this crazy
circular feel to this formation
which is why it's called the subway like
a tunnel so I want to tell you about the
tripod I've been using it's a brand new
tripod is actually not even for so I'm
just using the prototype from peak
design big design is makes this bag this
bag I've been using for three years they
came out with this tripod and I'm like
wait I kind of had thought of them as
like a bag making company and like
suddenly they're making a tripod okay so
they sent me this tripod I've been using
it a lot and have really held off on
giving thoughts on it until I really
used it well I've been using it and I
freaking love it like I love love it it
is tiny so many amazing little tactile
features that allow me to move it and
adjust it in really natural ways and yet
it's really light and it fits in the
water bottle compartment of my backpack
I love the plate that it comes with this
little square plate that you can use on
the tripod and then you can put it on
the little peep clip I've had the pig
clip forever but I've never actually
used it because I've always had a
Manfrotto plate on the bottom of my
camera so I'm really into it and I'm
gonna be using it now for everything and
no longer you're gonna be using my
Manfrotto tripod just sad Pete told me
they wanted feedback and any critiques
or downsides only thing I can think of
is if they have like a quick-release
plate that I could put on like my gimbal
and stuff so I could use this plate and
like quickly put it on my gimbal as well
or put it on other things like mount it
that would be amazing
wish the plate that the complaint on the
bottom could screw on and off with like
a hand screw instead of an allen wrench
I don't know these are tiny things I'd
like to scrape in the bottom of the
barrel here to like come up with
feedback but the reality is this is an
amazing tripod so tripods not for sale
yet because it is in the middle of a
Kickstarter camp is the cheapest now
that it will ever be so if you go
pre-order it now it'll be cheaper
there's carbon fiber and there's
aluminum and I've got the carbon fiber
which is feather-light if you lumina ms
great - it's just a bit heavier and
cheaper see it's like the perfect travel
tripod it really is like for the type of
filmmaking I do
nimble lean like I just need something
that's solid but small and this is this
does it so thank you peak design for
making a beautiful tripod thank you for
sending me this tripod thanks for
sponsoring this video your turning
around we're headed back down
subway
[Music]
you
[Music]